it brought everybody back sam what's
going on the obi-wan trailer just
dropped the other day thank you for
asking
one hand
somewhere somewhere somewhere well
that's the same way i think about dude
from you know
jurassic park somewhere riding around on
velociraptor
[Laughter]
that's a huge history of people with one
hand that's returning
the only person i've ever said that to
about coming back was bryce dallas
howard
good person to say that too and she
directs episodes and delorean stuff so
you think you might be able to right
hook a brother
you like me right
i like samuel l jackson pandering for a
role it's great put me back in the game
coach i'm ready
for getting that great question
definitely go check out the full show on
his patreon i don't know how he gets
these great questions out uh and gets
these amazing answers he's mr werewolf
got it straight from andrew garfield so
right
now my question is did did uh did samuel
jackson just accidentally admit that his
character from jurassic park is coming
back because he's like
he's like i'm doing a film with bryce
taylor
no no no it's a that's a different movie
that's a movie a spy movie called argyle
matthew
but yeah i thought the same thing i was
like wait a minute wait a minute what is
going on welcome back to new rock stars
mace windu is long overdue for a return
in star wars canon and samuel l jackson
himself confirmed wanting to do this so
it's now no longer a question of if but
really when and how is it gonna be in
the mandalorian season three or gonna be
perhaps even as soon as
i don't know but this is wikileaks our
weekly reaction to the latest in star
wars i'm here with a man who only needs
one hand to take care of business tommy
beck told i like my kenobi is becoming
more and more like scooby-doo every week
like i'm like rudolfi
bro it's a red eye
you're
become more powerful than you could
possibly imagine
you were my brother
you were the chosen one
[Laughter]
in today's episode we're going to talk
about sam jackson's recent comments
about returning his mace windu and
assuming he did survive the fall from
the chancellor's chambers on coruscant
where has the guy been since
well our merch partners at epic hero
shop just released two cool moon night
inspired hoodie designs they're a
perfect way to stylishly head into
spring while celebrating the show that
everyone is going to be talking about
the next few months to see those and all
the great merch options head on over to
epic hero shop.com tommy what's our big
star wars question this week baby we've
teased it we've pleased it and now it's
time to release it how will mace windu
return in star wars
what a release
um so mace windu's survival from order
66 isn't just fan headcanon it's been
acknowledged by jackson in the past and
approved even by george lucas in 2016
jackson was asked about this and he said
let's let's roll the clip here in my
mind i'm not dead jedis can fall
incredibly high
distances and not die and entertainment
weekly followed up with them and
confirmed that he talked about this with
george lucas who said i'm okay with that
you you can be alive i didn't i don't
want to commit fully to george lucas i
wasn't ready to go on it i need to keep
working on these movies there's more
aliens to put in
there's more droids to put in i can
extend these i can i can make these more
enriched and then they're like george
george he's shaking a star wars snow
globe and they're like we'll never know
what's going on in his mind it's just a
it's just an ad
in a snow globe um well i mean to be if
you look back at the behind the scenes
on uh the prequels i think was phantom
menace that same kind of conversation is
exactly how sam jackson got a purple
lightsaber he's like what about a what
about a purple lightsaber and george
lucas is essentially i'm okay with that
it could be purple and so the fact that
george lucas says the same thing to say
if it makes windows alive either he's
just like very intimidated by samuel
jackson yeah and he'll just agree to
anything he says uh or loves him that
much it's like anything you want this is
your universe now but uh i think now
jackson's comments are referring to the
conversation he had with actor director
bryce dallas howard on the set of the
upcoming math devon spy movie argyle
howard has directed some of the better
episodes of the mandalorian in the book
of bobopet and jackson's eager to return
to mace windu on one of these series now
bryce dallas tower did not direct any of
the six episodes of obi-wan kenobi all
those are being directed by debra chow
so the fact that jackson was asking
howard would suggest that he might not
show up in kenobi because if he was
showing up in kenobi why would he need
to ask that favor of bryce dallas howard
to put him in one of the other shows
unless tommy that answer is a clever
clever misdirect to make us think his
return is not coming as soon as obi-wan
kenobi he's just saying i'm just someone
who's still in a state of uh of
unknowingness
of uncertainty of when i'm gonna show up
in a title so i had to ask price dallas
howard when really he knows i don't know
if sam jackson really gives a [ __ ] about
playing that kind of 4d chess with fans
i don't think he works that way uh but
if mace windu were to show up in obi-wan
kenobi that would make a a bit more
sense that him showing up in the modern
era because right now in ob1 this is 10
years after order 66 the inquisitors are
still really in the process of finding
all the jedi survivors and stance the
reason mace could at least alluded to
capture for a decade obi-wan kenobi and
cassie and andor are both taking place
in that period between order 66 in a new
hope when the galactic empire is still
at its at its peak uh so timeline wise
either of those would be our best window
for windu maybe even to establish him as
the jedi who rescued grogu from the jedi
temple um now i'm just going to say this
i'm not saying i want this i'm just
saying it's possible that if lucasfilm
really wanted to they don't necessarily
need the actor samuel jackson to come
back to pull off this cameo like really
in order to establish his survivalist
canon all we need is just maybe that
shot of grogu and his bassinet pod as a
purple lightsaber in the foreground
slices through a bunch of the 500 first
clone troopers and then a figure limps
towards the pod and we all know what
that means
uh so jackson wouldn't even have to be
on in the loop on that uh because like
yes like if they show some version of
his face they'd have to credit his
likeness and he might have to sign off
on that i'm not sure i think lucasfilm
and disney kind of own the likeness of
mace windu at this point um
but they also don't even need to show
his face um but uh because samuel
jackson is so down to return for this i
i i want to see him on set for however
this is gonna go um and uh i think
that's like the truest return of both
the character and the actor i don't want
them to do it without him i'm just
saying there are plenty of ways this
could work at first to tee up uh his
return on screen uh for some other title
uh to bring mace windu back in the
mandalorian boba fett era would just
bring up a lot more questions because
the mandalorian takes place over 28
years after revenge of the sith that
would mean mace windu not only survived
order 66 but then just stayed out of all
the events of a new hope empire strikes
back return of the jedi even if he was
helping the rebellion in some unseen way
uh for him to not cross paths with like
obi-wan or yoda or luke during luke's
jedi training just seems like super
unlikely for the kind of warrior mace
windu is he's at the front of the line
you know
so i think if mace windu returns and
would
in whatever era he returns in the first
time we see him my opinion is i think
it'd be best to just introduce him via
flashback uh similar to that order 66
flashback in episode six of boba fett
just like explain the events of how he
survived at first that doesn't need to
be where we need to live with him
forever and ever it doesn't need to be
an obi-wan or even cassian end or it can
be in any of these series can just flash
back to that night whenever they want to
introduce him uh they could even use the
same de-aging tech they used on samuel
jackson and captain marvel they have the
technology that's right they can just
they could do it um and just use this
moment to establish how he survived for
the fans who don't already
like uh consider that to be the truth uh
you could even dovetail it onto that
groku in the dormitory scene in the book
of boba fett that flashback just showed
the second part of that scene who got
him out of that from a different point
of view and then uh that would set up a
future limited run series that could
show mace's years in hiding during that
bad batch era
as the galactic empire's taking over how
he got away from it and then give it to
bryce dallas howard she can direct all
this give us six episodes of that six
episodes and then we're all gonna watch
it it's gonna be one of your most
watched yes absolutely but if they want
to bring back mace windu in the later
era 980y when the mandalorian window fit
takes place um we're gonna just need a
bit of an explanation for where he was
during all those years during the
galactic civil war when luke really
needed him the most again there are
still many possibilities to that though
uh but the three i like
for where mace windu could have been for
nearly three decades
one he could have been palpatine's
prisoner all those years perhaps one of
the previous donors of imcount rich
blood
before grogu came along and took over
that role
uh the second option maybe he was frozen
in carbonite all those years and kept in
storage wow and then someone just forgot
he was there or three he could have been
in the world between worlds and we
already know technically in star wars
canon his voice did come from beyond it
was implied that his voice was coming
through either the nether regions of the
force maybe the world between worlds and
the rise of skywalker when he spoke to
rey so he's still out there in some form
uh either he's dead i assume at that
point by the sequel trilogy the guy's
dead uh but
like there there are areas other realms
that he could be in uh tommy i wanted to
ask you how how do you most want to see
mace windu return eric are you ready to
have your mind absolutely blown oh i
don't know i don't know if i'm right
here but you're gonna blow it in i had a
conversation with all screen producer
brandon about this exact topic and
together we formed a theory about how
mace windu could come back that i think
is pretty incredible and i almost
hesitate to share online
so
shortly after his uh confrontation with
anakin and emperor palpatine at that
point senator palpatine i believe i
don't think he had chancellor palpatine
thank you uh mace windu is of course
ejected uh thrown a great distance
badly wounded
uh and left for dead but anakin is no
fool he's about to be darth vader
anakin recovers the body
of mace windu badly beaten in
the same technology that is used to
repair vader
they repair mace windu they wipe his
memory and they turn him into an
inquisitor
so he is now a hard jedi part cyborg
inquisitor going around now this
eliminates the need for de-aging because
i'm talking he has like a kano metal
thing on his face he's got like we don't
necessarily need to de-age him we just
put a lot of mods on him
so he's now going around finding other
jedis until he runs into
obi-wan kenobi they have a fight obi-wan
kenobi recognizes his old
his former kind of not mentor but
another older jedi that had helped train
him and helped make him the jedi that he
was he uses his force the force of the
good to restore mesa's mind thus
creating kind of a
man without a country mace doesn't
necessarily have the old ways he's
probably disgusted with how the jedi's
ended he's also now probably disgusted
with himself and has a conflict of what
did he do while he was under the control
of vader and now he's forced to
you know make his way throughout the
galaxy which could also have him then
wind up on the mandalorian as a current
age samuel l jackson just kind of as a
like man as i said man without a country
hired gun with all these with this crazy
skill set and now all these mods
so that is how i'd like to see him come
back that's wild i mean that's like it's
like a another version of darth vader in
a lot of ways but like uh um someone
with more of a jedi association than a
sith association i i think like i'm glad
that you said that um the plan would be
to restore his memories because i think
if you're gonna bring him back like if
you bring anyone back at star wars you
want that opportunity to recall past
events yeah
and phantom menace to to have the
callbacks they they repeat the lines
that they say
um he's too dangerous to be left alive
or whatever it what you know whatever
quote you want adam a swindu um for me
like i love the idea that he could be a
representative of uh the jedi who never
really learned the error of the jedi
ways
like in in the original trilogy luke
doesn't have a whole lot of time to
spend with obi-wan kenobi and uh
with yoda
like he he seems to be
truly optimistic about bringing back the
jedi order um you know after the
galactic civil war ends and i'd love to
see some like
older jedi who survives who uh refuses
refuses to admit
that the jedi orthodoxy was flawed right
sure you know absolutely because mace
windu had that dogmatic of everyone on
the jedi council seemed to be the most
dogmatic uh the most disciplined about
uh the types of personalities that
belong on the jedi yes absolutely and
now imagine him being broken and looking
down at himself and seeing the remnants
of a killing machine that was created by
vader and and completely controlled by
vader for years what did he do
what did he do and now he's back and
he's got his old memories back and maybe
the the old and new memories are
conflicting maybe he's got like a
jason-born fractured brain
see i don't need him to have like a
fractured brain or like a ton of
cybernetic implants i think everyone at
star wars at some point is going to have
some mod upgrades but i don't think that
needs to completely change his mindset i
don't need like the
kind of terminator i want him to be able
to eric that's my pitch i want him to be
a boy so see i think like when a lot of
people hear this well where was he then
it's like the same thing uh of like the
argument i would have when people say
the x-men can't exist in the mcu because
why wouldn't they have helped it's like
the camera just wasn't pointing in that
direction
he could have been fighting in all kinds
of battles and we just didn't know there
were just other layers to the fight in
the same way that like the clone wars
series
showed us all these other adventures
that were happening behind the scenes if
you're to tell me that you know as a
revenge of the sith in 2005 they're like
no there can't be any more anakin and
obi-wan story because we didn't see it
in attack of the clones revenge of the
city right it's like
uh how come we didn't see ahsoka tano in
those movies
no she was there it's just the camera
wasn't pointed at her like
like they just chose not to put her in
that story in that sequence of events
the camera she wasn't in the frame but
she was still in the world at the time
so i think the same could be true for me
swindon you could have been helping the
galactic civil war in any number of ways
and it could it was like a terrorist
network from the empire's point of view
anybody who wasn't uh fitting in to
their regime uh was just someone who's
screwing things up for them and mace
windu could have been like slicing the
legs off at ats or he could have been uh
blowing up other super weapons that the
empire was trying to build he could have
been um
bombing uh palpatine's uh uh a summer
home yeah on a leak at a lake somewhere
yes absolutely i like i that's the
perfect way to put it the camera just
wasn't pointed at them i love i love
that i love that theory and that that
way of looking at right the stories so
yes i'm with you eric i'm with you and
it's like you know uh an end game they
had like an inelegant version of this
where they asked this that captain
marvel and she goes i was just saving
other players right so saving other
worlds like there could just be one line
of dialogue where samuel jackson says
that and then yells at us and then we're
all like yes sir yes we're sorry for
asking i was saving wookies okay no
problem yeah no problem works for me
works for me and i think we're gonna see
that in uh in kenobi what it looks like
when a jedi is truly in hiding uh like
obi-wan kenobi could have helped out he
could have helped out cassie and andor
he helped out all kinds of people no he
pretty much just stayed on a desert
planet looking after a kid you gotta
imagine how many rebels were pissed off
about that bale organa mon mothma know
that obi-wan is out there probably
plenty of missions where they're like
can this jedi war hero please help us
out on this one yeah and not until the
battle is scare after they're like okay
we absolutely need someone but he
doesn't help him out and that operation
really they're just like he'll just be
there to receive the the battle plans uh
from princess leia when she gets there
yes they don't ask him to leave tatooine
to help them out right so
anyway uh when a jedi is in exile i
think most people understand that like
leave them in exile they can help us in
other ways like they fought their wars
they don't need to help out with this
galactic civil war or maybe they don't
know that he survived but like i think
it's perfectly okay for a jedi to help
out in other ways that don't put him in
at the center of the rebel leadership
yeah we actually did get some
confirmation of a character who is going
to be in mandalorian season three or at
least an actor christopher lloyd
dr emmett brown
is joining this cast that's an amazing
casting wow there's so many great
options of characters he could play uh
we're going to talk about that more in a
bit but first we want to thank some
people who helped us make this episode
thank you to me undies for sponsoring
this episode everybody has a morning
routine maybe you drink coffee maybe
have the same breakfast every morning
you watch a new rockstars video while
you brush your teeth maybe your routine
includes changing into your favorite
pair of underwear which for us is always
super comfortable me undies oh yeah
they're truly the most comfortable
underwear once you try their undies
socks or loungewear you will never go
back choose from a range of limited
edition prints and colors and sizes from
extra small to 4xl you can also sign up
for their free to join me undies
membership where you get a monthly
subscription that sends new styles right
to your door plus enjoy discounted
pricing free shipping and exclusive
early access to new launches meundies
has a great offer for our listeners for
any first-time purchasers you get
fifteen percent off and free shipping
meundes also has their promise if you're
not satisfied with any product for any
reason you can return your order for a
full refund within 45 days to get your
15 off your first order and free
shipping go to meundies.com wookie
that's meondas.comwookie1e
we also want to thank masterclass for
sponsoring this episode with masterclass
you can learn from the world's best
minds anytime anywhere and at your own
pace you can learn science from bill nye
learn drumming from ringo starr even
learned basketball from steph curry with
over 100 classes from a range of
world-class instructors that thing
you've always wanted to do is closer
than you think here at new rockstars
we're huge fans of the writing process
and the filmmaking process uh so we like
taking those kind of classes they've got
classes from big directors uh writers
actors even have classes from both danny
elfman and hans zimmer two absolute
movie score titans so if you can't
decide between who has a better batman
score yeah uh you can you can just take
the best of both worlds uh the class
from sandman creator neil gaiman on
storytelling is amazing he covers
everything from how to discover your
writing voice to how to overcome
writer's block the classes are really
well produced and you can watch them on
your computer smart tv or any device
where you stream these are actual
projects for you to do so the learning
is immersive and more active we highly
recommend you to go check it out get
unlimited access to every master class
and for the new rockstars audience you
can get 15 off an annual membership so
go to masterclass.com
wookie that's wookie with two e's and
thank you to peloton for sponsoring this
episode fear is the mind killer and
boredom is the exercise killer doing the
same workout over and over can sap your
motivation to exercise and hurt your
fitness progress that's where our
friends at peloton can help with their
awesome peloton app you don't need to
own one of the cool peloton bikes to use
the app for classes and workouts they
have new classes new music and new ways
to keep your workouts fun and motivating
peloton is a workout for every day and
every schedule de-stress from a long day
with 30 minutes of strength and 20
minutes of cardio or do a quick
15-minute total body class before work
stay motivated while having fun with
bike workouts yoga meditation dance
cardio and more they have some very cool
boxing classes that i'm eager to try you
don't need to have ever boxed before you
don't even need the gloves you can build
up an excellent sweat while learning
fundamentals of boxing and channeling
your inner welterweight champion you can
use the app on all your devices play it
on your tv to work out in the living
room or bring your phone or tablet out
to the yard for some sun and sweat
outdoors so if you want to add some
great motivating variety to your
workouts check out the peloton app by
clicking the link in the video's
description or visit onepeloton.com to
learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
tommy what's our next question i am so
excited to ask this question and i'm so
excited to find out the answer when it
happens who will christopher lloyd play
in the mandalorian season three it's so
exciting like we don't even know what
character he's playing it just seems
like it's long overdue for christopher
lloyd to show up in star wars like let's
get this guy in the marvel cinematic
universe too like why isn't he worked
more he's so amazing not just in like
the back of the future films but he'd be
a great uh
like scott lang variant like like an old
ant-man from another universe oh yeah
just because he's kind of guy
i mean he's not like good as
good-looking as paul red but he's got
the same kind of charm and can be
dramatic i think he's hotter than paul
rudd that's what i meant to say yeah
he's got the same kind of charm but also
able to convey real emotions in his
acting so like if you had him as like a
different scott lang you know almost the
way uh who was the guy that played the
great loki richard uh what is his last
name uh
uh richard e graham yes oh like the way
he handled playing classically anyway
sorry i think no no i think that's a
good take i think like he not only can
ham it up of course as doc brown like so
much of the joy of the back to future
trilogy is just on christopher just to
face shoulders
and to be honest like uh of course
michael j fox's uh um um marty mcfly
like you can see so much of what he did
in that role show up with what tom
holland is doing in the spider-man films
like it's almost like a beat for beat
impersonation of marty mcfly in those
movies but christopher lloyd was the
second half of that coin and like the
way he could make us laugh in the in the
role he played and also make us
terrified
of the consequences
of the space-time continuum unraveling
um now this role is described as a guest
star role so it may just be in one
episode or a couple episodes the way
like werner herzog in the first season
of the mandalorian i'm just kind of
there for a few episodes to lend his
amazing voice to this role yes um so you
could just imagine him as some other uh
leader within the imperial ranks uh or
whatever you know uh a moff gideon
ally or someone working with thrawn but
i actually think uh
let's consider him as perhaps someone
representing the new republic leadership
uh you had talked when we were when we
were covering the book of boba fett
where the mandalorian season 3 is going
to go
maybe visiting moff gideon's trial with
the new republic judicial system yes uh
it could be fun to see christopher lloyd
play some senator from the original
republic era who's now like uh kind of
the elder in the room i was just like we
can't make the same mistakes that we
made before
but no one listens to him shut up old
man
or
or he's saying that but it's a double
cross and he's the one that frees moff
gideon oh he's corrupt corrupt a corrupt
lloyd corrupt lloyd they got his uh uh
his granddaughter uh kidnapped and he
like you better release them off gideon
or your granddaughter gets it i kind of
wonder if like if if it is the
mandalorian at some point we're gonna be
visiting the living waters of the minds
of mandalore could uh he represent some
mandalorian elder oh that would be
amazing someone who's from the armorers
generation uh
but he does not he's someone else
because we have the armorer who's kind
of like the the bastion of authority and
knowledge within the mandalorian
survivor network but she's uh kind of a
zealot you know she's insane in her
orthodoxy so we need some other
masculist mandalorian who can represent
the other side of that philosophy and
truly stand toe-to-toe with her and
debate her on something i could see
christopher lloyd playing that yeah
really well i agree i would love to see
that yeah yeah someone else that like
mando feels pressured to listen to like
someone else like do i want to follow
you off a cliff actually because you're
just as crazy but what you're saying
makes more sense maybe maybe and maybe
what he's yeah and what he's saying is
like we we were wrong to be so rigid and
so absolute in our rules you know kind
of mirroring the jedi code you know and
how some of the uh
the older jedi's came to see kind of how
ridiculous all that orthodoxy was you
know even even yoda in uh in the rise of
skywalker going
like paige turner's they are not you
know or that was yeah that was last jedi
right last jedi yeah last jedi um it's
fine but like i think that's
uh what we want to see from uh uh from
that character is he has a mix of like
insanity but also like the crazy old man
you want to listen to uh and like he
could represent all the other sides of
the mandalorian culture say we didn't
our our culture didn't get eradicated
because boko tan picked up a blade that
she didn't rightfully win uh we didn't
lose our ways because some of most of us
wanted to not walk around with helmets
on our head all day like there was a
vibrant mandalorian culture uh and a
tradition in the history that is more
mainstream than what you have been led
to believe is the only way so let me
tell you my my version of events of why
we got bombed in the night of uh
thousand tears there is one character
from star wars lore from star wars
legends that we have to mention
as a perfect perfect casting i think for
christopher lloyd a crazy old bat by the
name of joris sabio yes so
this old uh insane man was a uh
character from they're now legends but
they're thrawn stories so you know
thrawn is coming into live action uh you
know in at some point either in ahsoka
or in the mandalorian season three so
presumably this guy could as well it
seems like felony's whole mission is
just to bring the best parts of legends
into star wars canon once more so
originally this guy was a jedi master
who led the outbound flight project kind
of like uh uh almost like moses leading
a new civilization through the the
desert or you can imagine it like star
trek like uh finding new worlds to
settle into colonize uh but this fleet
was found and destroyed by thrawn um and
the jurists poor old joris was captured
uh and this is when uh during the
galactic civil war era palpatine
found him and essentially took his uh uh
uh
dna and cloned him making him this
insane figure of jorus with two u's uh
and basically defied palpatine and went
off on his own and it's just this
awesome character who represents like a
a strict
uh approach a strict philosophy of uh
the jedi mindset but it's just
completely
in in another space luke actually finds
him in some comics and uh and trains
with them briefly
um but just like can't just cannot get
on the same page with them and then he
ends up leaving with mara jade after
george tries to kill mario chad with
boulder oh yeah okay fair enough he's a
really really cool character it's just
this insane hermit that would be really
fun
to pair this era of luke in ahsoka i
like that in the rule of threes it's
like
obi-wan kenobi described as an insane
hermit not really yoda described as an
insane hermit a little wacky but not
necessarily insane and then this guy
described as an insane hermit fits the
billing tries to kill a jedi
yes
like uh the fact that we spend a whole
episode with uh young luke i think i
think they're gonna be eager to try that
again uh i don't know if the mandalorian
season three is gonna spend a lot of
time with young luke and ahsoka or that
might just be something that they leave
for the asuka series but like
never in a thousand years would i have
imagined the book of boba fett would
have spent an entire episode with just
like luke and grogu in ahsoka on it on
like a lush green planet so the fact
that like they did that on the book of
beaufort means that like they could
totally do it in the mandalorian season
three absolutely the way these series
are structured is like they're going to
be random one-off episodes that just
follow other characters absolutely so
that could be what they mean by just
casting him in like a one-off uh guest
role right
and if you could if i had to pick anyone
from star wars legends that i i would
want him like if they're gonna bring in
someone who already exists who isn't
just like a new character i'd love it to
be jurists if not i'd i if it's gonna be
a new character who doesn't exist
already i i'd love it for him to be some
kind of mandalorian elder character who
can just represent some some other kind
of ideology oh what do you think tommy i
you know i think of all of that i i the
thing that would be most exciting for me
would be uh to go back to your origin or
your the middle uh suggestion having him
be some sort of mandalorian elder that
is this kind of the counterweight to the
armorer like just yeah for every reason
that you said you know just like
still you know maybe even rigid in his
resistance to the old ways in in his in
his in his reluctance to have anyone
else go there just someone to kind of
continue the pull
that uh that uh that uh jin jardin is uh
is being pulled with or dean jardin is
being pulled with already after being
kind of you know excommunicated from the
mandalorians but still
he's such a like a a straight arrow that
it's like even even being exiled he's
like yeah well you know i'm still gonna
follow the ways probably so yeah i think
the fact that the armorer shunned him
just upon his confession that at some
point someone saw him under his mask i
think the long arc for denjarin on this
series is that uh he's he started as
someone firmly rooted
in
the watches mindset of this is the way
and it was such an interesting
introduction because to those of us
watching the animated series there's
plenty of mandalorian characters in
mandalorian culture who is not that
strict so like that isn't it it's like
watching someone be detoxicated from a
cult that's the story of this absolutely
yep and and so we need someone else who
can kind of break him free to help him
go clear
uh well to you know what i mean to go
dark
to break him from that mindset and
really confront the the orthodoxy that
we've heard from the armorer um and to
maybe teach him when he goes to the
living waters that he does not need to
rejoin the rot the watch that that's not
his way no there is another way
there's another way
life will find that we'll find a way
we'll leave it there for this episode of
wikileaks don't forget to check out our
great merch options at nurexersmerch.com
as always we're going to be here every
week discussing star wars news whatever
your biggest questions are please ask us
yes uh
hashtag wikileaks i guess with two e's
uh but tag me and tommy on twitter to
let us know what biggest questions you
have about star wars specifically yes uh
if you tweet us and if it's the question
we talk about we'll shout you out on
this show that's right just as a little
little motivation there
you follow me at ea boss follow tommy at
tommy bechtel follow the rockstar
subscribe to wikileaks wherever you get
your podcasts thank you for watching and
uh goodbye
you